[Music]
[Music]
i say what i say then i have to go
stayed in my lane never had to fold the
piece man i met come wrong i admit never
had take parts like nagato this one cute
in my camera
sweetie wants to ring like haribo but
i'm in two minutes that's you and the
queen keeps calling i go
go get you so special content bruce no
drip come wall step through cold trees
come pull me man choke
ain't nothing new man i cut through
loads ridiculous i never want to be
conspicuous and the drop came true but
we missed a bit we risk a bit hit one
thing i triple it and the stuff that i
do for my brodies
that i don't want back and i still gotta
see them rats i had to let go cause they
held man back that's nothing but facts
where you hit let me wait on postman pat
my bros like mitch
i'll be throwing them packs they need
out to the stack don't know no better
used to go homes on the bench with bro
young style not a pack real fat like
ever
don't gloat stay low see your cash flow
and keep from the pigs like pepper
yeah she real cute but not real clever
italian drip something that she can't
get
still looking for my envelope my back
snakes and my team that's something that
i can't take
something that can't run she thought you
were done but i'll be far from it see
i've always been first not the last one
roll to the top you can see what the
class does
and my bro made hits from the streets
cleaning up time bought me from the
deets see
i'll shine now she want me see y'all
shine now she want eat
oh about being real stubborn still gotta
make my pee from a touch of a button
like it's all or nothing eyes on gang
when you pull up to the function
but come loud and we call it in
abundance stay around there if you're
hating assumptions
like burning more time around them all
count that up and do it by the hundreds
see i do it on my bro
on my own on a one man army and i like
girls cute
partly rude of a touch of nasty and
classy b
please don't charge me and i do it for
the loan my charge you see shawty i
don't play boy like cartier
bro went north i think john with snow
started slow then he got [ __ ] flopping
i don't go back bro knows all when i
stay in the ends just seeing my profit
that my skin and i keep with in time
don't wait so i watch where the clock is
bro gotta drop and i gotta log in
hold this talking lows let me pray don't
lock it they want elderly we made that
back
ain't no check cause we made that fact i
went low but i made my stack and i keep
it going to the phrase my back on
ramadan till they ain't like gank on run
with them because they ain't like man
i mean see that they trash bit facts but
we know that it's not about
you